à bâle voilà tu étais le cochon voir
hier j'étais avec kad nous tes deux
voire trois avec jonathan lambert mais
surtout une scène deux
parties de pétanque avec la noix de coco
tu es là moi ton alcool de riz tu as dit
que ça s'appelle déjà chaque eh eh ben
c'est ça qui est beau bon et on passe
une sacrée bonne journée riquet mal
avant même de bouffer pense d'abord à
boire et sa soeur alcool nous le jeu de
mon sac et on a passé un sacré bon
moment pour but d'abaisser bien le sac
et un attouchement les coûts choisi je
plaisante tu sais j'ai dû en touche et
un sacré paquet de couillonnade jungle
et se trouve que dans la série gérard et
moi nos deux personnages vont se
rapprocher de plus en plus voilà on
chine c'est le bois sont typiques la
colle de ninja 5
seulement commença à se découvrir des
atouts et des charmes insoupçonnés
et on commence à
se demander si c'est possible parce que
c'est plus de poser des questions au
fils des buzz
ce que je peux t'appeler fichiers c'est
ça ta question oui oui tu peux merci mon
fils nous atomes crochus et
je suis pas objectif du tout donc même
quand il dit une grosse connerie pas
drôle ça
très drôle
[Musique]
par contre on va bien rigoler
excellence à
gérard comme moi comme je connais bien
et que il avait tellement aimé la saison
une qui m'a dit tu m'as n'aime pas
appelé avant une merde mais truc comme
ça je dis bon bah il aya une place pour
toi c'est pour toi quoi philippe machete
est un ancien militaire de carrière
reconverti en romancier davanture une
orange parle de la guerre jean-philippe
machette c'est une des grandes barres de
rire à l'écriture c'est vraiment pour le
coup c'est un personnage un peu inspiré
de tropic thunder tonnerre sous les
tropiques où le personnage de nick nolte
dans la jungle la jungle et kim jong-il
est censé le film est adapté du bouquin
qu'il a écrit le mec a une maman - il
fait n'importe quoi d'escarres partout
et tout est à auray c'est une immense
arnaque que donne le temps et ça ce
personnage là les trouvais génial je me
dis c'est génial d'avoir un personnage
de ce type dans une série d' aventure
comme ça où tout le monde est à fond
tout le monde s'entraîne pendant des
années lui fait croire et tout c'est un
expert est en fait c'est la plus grosse
en fument mais non fumeur ou encore flou
tu t'en sors avec la machette bien sûr
on sort avec la machette c'est un gros
mytho qui n'a jamais rien vécu de tout
ce qu'il raconte et ineum dit que des
conneries il invente tout c'est un mythe
au total alors ça c'est un de mes
derniers ouvrages film machete à l'école
des sorciers parce que moi j'ai fait
l'école des sorciers figurez vous dire
que mon puissance auprès de l'un de ses
balles dont le croire jusqu'à la
jusqu'au bout il va quand même faire
cesser ces aveux et son coming out je
veux dire par là
enfin c'est n'importe quoi on n'est
nulle part là on dit nulle part
quoi
ton bordeaux
il était à gauche hier c'est la gauche
la droite aujourd'hui un coq nous c'est
pareil elles sont dans la chasse au
trésor ils sont perdus parce que l'hôte
est une arnaque d'aventuriers carole des
coûts qu'en fait son bandeau il voit
très bien [ __ ] tu vois tu vois tu
attends avec une [ __ ] de grosses
arnaques en fait ces armes là c'est le
personnage de gérard qu'est effondrée
parce que tout ce qu'on veut c'est cool
et l'autre qui quoi qu'il arrive restent
eux sont à 1000m et les deux s'aiment
depuis le début c'est une brome ans qui
finit en couple tu tapes la honte honte
ou de quoi rentrer de quoi honte de quoi
hé bé de tout ce qui s'est passé qu'est
ce qui s'est passé de quoi monpilou
tous les jours mais j'oublie l'aventuré
mais toi
et sûrs que je te dise la vérité
n 13 en toi et tu viens à nîmes je tends
ferme dans la bodega et je te garde pour
moi tout seul
tu sais toi peu trop besoin de tellement
fermé était parce que je m'appelle
attention mon fils du patient parce que
moi je vais te passer directement de
l'alpil devant tout le monde attention
moi je déclenche chez les ch'tis zola
ne parle pas du showbiz ou pas tu
risques de tomber sur un adversaire
beaucoup plus fort que toi abou madi
prouve-le arrêt pour le vase y aller
ouais
[Musique]
e
comment
je dois dumont
plus
tu sens bon
[Musique]
si je suis fatiguée d'affaires
de raku peu avant non mais non mais en
fait déjà le bisou quand vous êtes
ensemble j'y crois pas le dernier là
quand vous en passer ah oui mais c'est
super avancé magique et à la fin vous
vous sabotez tout avec votre faux bisou
au bien manger pour mettre en place pour
les pousser pour être néanmoins quand il
se cachait pour le bisou en fait qui le
donne pas toulouse a progressé il faut
qu'ils soient alors que la qui jouent le
jeu et qui s'en inspirent de vrai là
c'est exceptionnel l'art les persos en
fait ils se cachent pas niveau
[Musique]
content c'est un vrai moment de comédie
et en même temps de pureté de d'émotion
et et franchement trop content qu'on ait
réussi à aller à cet endroit là c'est
trop rarement les comédies c'est marrant
de voir comment dire d'être dans des
archétypes des terreaux rentrée voilà
essais mais qu'elle va avec tout ce
qu'on peut imaginer 2,26 m ils s'aiment
deux hommes qui s'aiment et sa chose à
très très beau à devenir aujourd'hui
maintenant
dans notre société et dans une scène de
comédie et dans ce genre de séries pas
[Musique]